♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FORMER DONALD TRUMP
ADVISOR ROGER STONE SAID THERE
WAS POSSIBLY ANOTHER CASE OF FBI
MEDDLING IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
IN 2016.
HE WAS APPROACHED BY A MAN WHO
WENT BY THE NAME OF HENRY
GREENBERG.
HE WANTED TO SELL THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN DAMAGING INFORMATION
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
AND GREENBERG WAS APPARENTLY AN
FBI INFORMANT, AND HE BELIEVES
THE ENTIRE SCHEME WAS AN EFFORT
BY THE FBI TO SET UP THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WHAT IS THE TRUTH?
ANDY McCARTNEY IS A
CONTRIBUTOR
COUNTERFEITING EDITOR AT THE
NATIONAL REVIEW AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE STORY?
>> IT'S YET ANOTHER ONE OF THESE
STORIES WHERE THERE IS A RUSSIAN
INVOLVED.
THERE MUST BE COLLUSION AND IT
MUST FIT INTO THE NARRATIVE
SOMEHOW, BUT IT REALLY
DOESN'T -- THERE IS NO LIMIT
YOUR CONNECTION ANYMORE TO ME AT
LEAST FOR ALL THESE STORIES AND
WHAT THE ORIGINAL ALLEGATION
WAS, WHICH WAS THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE KREMLIN.
NOT JUST ASSORTED RUSSIANS, BUT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, TO
COMMIT ESPIONAGE TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION OR TO CHANGE THE RESULT
OF THE ELECTION.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, IF THERE
WAS ANYTHING TO THIS PARTICULAR
STORY, WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT TO
SEE ALL THE FACTS THAT COME OUT,
BUT WHY AREN'T PEOPLE IN
HANDCUFFS ALREADY?
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAS HE CHARGED?
AND HAS NO ONE BEEN CHARGED WITH
ANY KIND OF COLLUSION EFFECT?
>> Tucker: IT WILL THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE GUY APPARENTLY HAD WORKED
FOR THE FBI BEFORE, HE CITED THE
FBI" LIST OF THE CELL PHONE
NUMBER OF AN FBI AGENT AND THE
NUMBER OF HIS IMMIGRATION
APPLICATIONS.
APPARENTLY HE WAS ON THEIR
PAYROLL IN SOME CAPACITY.
COMING TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFERING SECRETS FROM THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, NOW HE WOULD
SEEK OUT THE TEXTS THAT PROVED
THAT IT HAPPENED.
WHAT ARE THE ODDS THAT THAT IS
NOT AN FBI OPERATION?
>> THIS GUY APPARENTLY WORKED
FOR THE FBI FOR 17 YEARS AND
SUPPOSEDLY ACCORDING TO HIS
VERSION OF IT, JUST ENDED THAT
RELATIONSHIP IN 2013.
IN MY EXPERIENCE, FOR WHAT IT'S
WORTH, THERE ARE LIKE OFFICIALLY
SIGNED UP INFORMANTS AND THERE
ARE INFORMANTS WHO SPOKE AROUND
AND LISTEN TO STUFF.
WHEN I WAS A PROSECUTOR I
LEARNED NOT TO BELIEVE IN
COINCIDENCE.